it's a technologist I wanted to the
person who was here before I think was
Josh mentioned the mac to pc ratio and
as a technologist i'm always observing
some of these things and I think
yesterday we are achel was more like 621
I think today we're a little bit lower
than that but I noticed so many of them
also running a windows the max that are
running windows I want to take two
seconds out of my talk just to thank a
couple people hacker named brianna who
have been very involved in making sure
this event would run the way that it has
and also to Martin and Steve who keep
coming up here and helping everybody so
our production so they've won
and then they make things a lot easier
for us one other piece of another
announcement the round tables that are
set to happen during the lunch break
what we're going to do is have those two
of them in this room and the rest in the
room across the way room number is 107 I
forget the room number but it's right
across the way and if we can have the
music and international affairs one in
this room and the others in the other
space that would be great informal
meetings if we can just generate some
discussions around some of those topics
the people's whose names are on the
agenda will kind of be around and
identify themselves as we get those
started so the the title of this session
is best practices at the intersection of
technology and education I did a Google
search for that I got almost a million
hits since that everything's been said
so another thing that I decided to do
that's going to be a little different is
that rather than partly because of all
the planning for the conference how'd it
get it get a chance to do a lot of
picking up slides that I wanted to or
images that i want to have behind me as
i talk i just figured out that google
juice for me so let me start with the
center and one of the things that i like
to do when we think about the future of
technology it's kind of just take a step
back it gives me a really a chance to
have a more solid run up before we take
some of those leaps of extrapolation and
in this way you know we can get a better
sense of where we might hey when frank
Peretti and i started the center in in
late nineteen ninety eight there was a
land rush at the university it was a
time when there were a lot of media
initiatives and some of these were bored
out already in the at the center and
these initiatives included places like
fathom included places like the center
for new media
if the journalism school led by John
public here on the bottom of the bottom
so Google does a fairly good job at
picking the things that I wanted on
Morningside ventures it included a that
became digital knowledge ventures ascent
to that was part of the Arts now what
the reason for that is that I bring all
these things up is in 1998 there was a
lot of competition for after the faculty
interest and what we're talking about
here what I'm trying to talk about is
the work that we do at the center which
is directly with the faculty and trying
to get them to use technology in a
purposeful way and that competition was
was very strong them even our own book
store Barnes & Noble in 1998 was sending
emails to all of our faculty saying that
and I quote they can create a website
that delivers course content and
facilitates communication between you
and your students barnes and noble is
was promising a simple interface and
five minutes to get the job done we had
an outfit called sweet matcom that
developed the psychic force notes and
they actually use provost allen
Brinkley's course as a sample site now
this would be three years before we
actually launched our own force works
course management system at Columbia I
think that's very interesting even more
interesting is that and Eric brought
that up that by the time that got
launched most of those centers that I
mentioned no longer lived were no longer
at the University the
oops the in late nineteen ninety-eight
another piece of news was that we had a
dial-up modem pool now most most people
may not remember that but that was a
critical piece of infrastructure for the
University heavily utilized the
University IT department released a
statement that fall in 1998 that by the
end of September we would have 506 56k
modems by it also in 1998 we were using
blue and white key threes from a company
that was about to disintegrate at that
time everybody was thinking that Apple
was no longer going to exist we were
using machines that were clock speeds of
about two hundred fifty six megahertz
and 256 megabytes was considered ample
some of us use laptops even then instead
of using a desktop unit but if we wanted
to connect one of these things to one of
these projectors we would have to pay oh
seven thousand dollars or so and if we
want an affordable projector we had to
carry a big bag a big issue in the 1998
in terms of privacy was the finger
debate now some of you may not know what
finger is on the unix environment but it
was a system not very dissimilar from
the way on IM you can keep track of your
buddies at that time the issue was that
finger might be used as a way to stalk
somebody and so that was a big debate
the outcome was that you had to end up
you had to opt-in into the system and so
tas teaching assistants had to identify
themselves and opt-in so their charges
could be could find them in the student
last around the same time in 1998 that
the MCA was signed October 28 1998
similarly notes from university senate
meeting diet that
I attended around that that I wrote in
my notes here November I had a chance to
speak to some of the folks on the senate
meeting and I explained to them what
spam was and it was becoming a problem
and that was the understanding
understatement of the year late nineteen
ninety eight we also received a real
media g2 server which was making
streaming video reality it was hard to
read it's hard to recreate that
excitement that we felt at that time we
had been able to stream the audio fairly
well in fact I had worked out a deal
with the W VAR barnard college radio
station to stream their audio feed and
complement their very puny FM
transmitter they had all of these audio
feeds were working ok but video was a
new new place for us now with the g2
server we could send video streams that
were viewable by those 56k modems and
they were postage stamp-sized but there
were fabulous for us at that time it
wasn't really until 2000 that we
utilized that system in a large scale
and that's when we ended up doing the
commencement exercises in that year this
is pictures from that same same day well
what have we learned about technology
and education in those eight years and
we've gone through a lot a lot of the
staff that is here you know we worked on
a lot of different projects and issues
with faculty but we've learned a few
things and let me highlight three of
them that I think are very important
that is that the first one is that we
have to ask a lot of questions and
listen to the Faculty's interested
outcomes what is that they're trying to
get students to learn and we really try
to hammer that home with our staff as
much as we can another thing that we
is that we need a lot of time for
brainstorming and allowing discussions
to bloom there seems to be or there is
always a tendency especially when
dealing with technology to jump very
quickly at familiar solutions and so we
have to always leave room for extended
discussion and just from the few things
that I mentioned there in recalling the
1998 is that we also have to understand
that today's technology will soon wilt
under the constant change that we see
today for example we certainly would not
have had this kind of conference in 1998
no way what kind of conference will we
have in 2015 I would like to make two
other points about the intersection of
technology and education first at that
intersection of technology and education
I think we find now a open market an
open street market many products on the
baddest of web services web two point O
got some good ones here the one on the
on the bottom here says web two point O
isn't a thing it's a state of mind we
have all these things at our disposal we
have google youtube flickr delicious
wikispaces typepad what's interesting is
so many of the services fit a
constructivist agenda and that makes our
mountains water you take a look at the
at the offerings just in the area of web
editing and here's an article from
TechCrunch which some of you may be
familiar with and here's a summary of
some of the things are now available for
you to edit video online cuts eye spy
tomcod even have a little graphic here
to tell you which ones do what kind of
services
again this has been an area that's
typically been reserved for people who
use Final Cut Pro or iMovie next to
those same open market stands or the
open-source folks and you know they're
quite a quite a number of interesting
tools there as well just bring up some
of those should hit of penguins
somewhere along the way there but we
have WordPress Drupal Moodle cornucopia
of options but i have i have to say that
we have to cut be cautious about that
marketplace because near all these
stands is the university's IT stand and
they seem to be lacking in some of these
alternatives and for us who work inside
the university and are not part of the
university's IT mission this is very
important and I think for those IT
departments who have led the way so
often at the universities it is going to
be a difficult matter you look at the
steps like schools like Arizona State
have taken they move their email
calendar and ichat all over to to Google
so as the options to the University
become more and more plentiful and more
attractive and more students and faculty
move off campus for the technology
support well universities become
protectionists they have purple rules
they have all these we have all these
things that we have to deal with or will
IT departments decide a better path and
become integrators adopting initiatives
like open ID and both foot and opening
up their their own data sources through
in exposing them for our own internal
mashups we don't know but I think what
we do know is that the pace and scale
outside the universities is no match for
what the internal IT departments can do
now second point at that same
intersection of technology in education
we also find the students when I ran
into a quote from Thomas Thomas
Friedman's book the world is flat he
says to following
students also have to fundamentally
reorient what they're learning and
educators how they are teaching it I
felt like he was talking to us at the
center and those of us who are
monitoring this intersection back to
Friedman he he cost us for students to
be great collaborators to be great
synthesizers among many other team
things to compete in this new flat world
this is exactly our work but I think we
make one assumption that is false the
assumption we make is that these
students are literally a technology
literate enough to use their computers
for education now this is an opinion one
that is based on a number of
observations a colleague of ours John
Zimmerman is actually embarking on a
small research project to test this
hypothesis but I think typically find
that our students don't know enough
about how to use their computers as a
tool for education of the kind of work
that I've been describing I think it's
no big secret that a lot of our own
colleagues don't either but I think we
as educators in the technology field
need to make a concerted effort to help
people learn how to leverage their
computer use in this in this arena after
all the tool is just a way to get more
and more leverage for our work to close
out and really what an anecdote I
recently met with the coordinator of a
postdoc program here at Columbia and
she's designing a number of online
programs for these students and was
concerned about the students
overwhelming mastery of technology
compared to her she seemed surprised
when I explained to her that
this the technol student myth and when I
asked you to really think about how much
her students use their computer to
collaborate to annotate synthesize and
collate information I think it gave us
some pause but I think she will only be
convinced when she begins working with
some of these students and I hope that
many of you will also take that
challenge and see how we can be better
educators on the use of technology I
like to stop here and move over to our
next speaker which is Shen and we'll
have the guys come up and switch over
thank you